leute leute das youtube treffen fieber
ist ausgebrochen und nachdem wir auf der
gamescom ja einen lustigen hatten
geht es weiter mit sensationellen
youtube treffen und das nächste bei dem
ich leider nicht dabei sein kann aber
nicht gehört aber wird kann die dasein
ist am zweiten oktober in berlin es gibt
ja da auch diese super seminar zweiter
und dritter täter vom video ab
wer sich zum thema youtube austauschen
will
videos mal und so weiter da hingehen es
gibt auf der you einen treffpunkt
soweit ich weiß auch gar nicht jetzt von
einem guru linz in den anmerkungen und
im infotext und würde seinen am zweiten
zehnten auf der jugend treffpunkt ist um
12 uhr auf dem gelände wie gesagt links
gleich hier im video mit etwas mehr
details um 32 geht es dann im raum rhein
dort kann man landesweit nachgucken
bis 15 uhr und danach geht's zur messe
erkundung auf die eu also wieder ein
youtuber treffen
in berlin diesmal habe ich wünsche viel
spaß sende meine größte hit ich kann
leider nicht wer auch gerne gekommen
auch zu der geschichte vom video haben
mit dem ich mich ja wieder vertragen
habe
aber leider leider ich kann absolut
nicht
wir gehen mit nochmal meine größe und
euch allen die dort hinfahren viel spaß
und haltet die ohren scheint